why don't you want to have sex with me
though i don't understand
we will have sex
she's not gonna let this go kim tries to
seduce usemen and after she has a little
too much to drink things turn into a
crying mess
do you think my son would love them when
you're treating me right now
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia before
we get into kim and oosman we have to
talk about this elephant in the room
i'm alina i'm 27 years old and i'm from
st petersburg russia yes
tlc fired alina due to her past racial
social media posts that have resurfaced
we're not going to show you the post but
i saw screen grabs where she used the
n-word multiple times and she made jokes
about indian people and polygamy but
here's what she told me weeks ago when
we were talking about discrimination
online i don't really see you know a lot
of homophobic and racist comments
anymore because people really know that
it's not okay and it is not okay right
but
for some reason there is not much talk
about ableism honestly all this is
disappointing i was rooting for you we
were all rooting for you how dare you
starting next month alina will no longer
appear on 90 day fiance before the 90
days
she will not appear on the upcoming
tell-all or any future seasons of the
franchise so for those of you who enjoy
seeing caleb with his shirt off soak it
in now or
watch some reruns i really want you to
stay with me i really do all right let's
get into kim and usman last episode
usman finally slept in kim's hotel room
for the first time after she continued
to press him about it but before they
went to bed he built a pillow wall
between them so kim wouldn't
[Music]
[Applause]
touch him while he's asleep in the night
if i didn't put to my kitchen i was just
a zoop and that i don't think i'm gonna
you think i would do that to you fast
forward to the top of this week's
episode we see kim and usman waking up
next to each other
and although they didn't get intimate
like kim hoped and then yeah so you just
fell asleep so
damn it she is on top of the world right
now do you know you were like singing in
your seat
you were just like humming a tune
but it was really cute i still haven't
kissed him but he was like touching
certain body parts and i was like hey
it was pretty cool
lovely way for me to wake up today look
at the glow look at the glow do we glow
it's from him wait he still hasn't
kissed her
that's a damn shame all this sex talk
from kim makes you forget that they
haven't even shared their first kiss yet
i enjoyed the night well i'm glad she
did waking up to you in the morning was
nice too yeah
so maybe i should come into your room
again
at this point usman decides that he's
going to move into kim's room and later
on that night he explains to his manager
badminton and assistant slam t why he
thinks this is the right time i hope
kimberly will understand that the reason
why i'm moving into her room is because
it's the only way for us to get to
know each other to get close to each
other
it doesn't mean that we have a
relationship yet
so like if i move into her room that is
when from now on to ending of the time
that's when i can make the final
decision
slam tea is looking like bro i'm tired
of going along with this meanwhile kim
is in her room getting ready honey with
champagne and all
tonight is the night in her mind i am
trying to seduce susan i guess that's
what's going on
that's what's going on good luck with
that this is like a do or die moment and
i have to do it so i have my hey
liquid courage i'm cute
i have no makeup on like he likes me i
had my little laundry on so cheers to
possibly getting some tonight oh cheers
girl because
trust me i know it's hard not to create
expectations when you're into someone
but one thing you can't do is force
someone to change their mind he already
said what he said he's not having sex
i think it's too early for us to have
sex hey in this moment she's just
setting herself up for disappointment oh
wow why did you do that i just did it i
thought it was pretty good like like go
walk up to the edge and look at it yay
good
wow this bed looked like
a groom is coming to his bride room
but i am not surprised because the thing
is that i know
who is kimberly and i know what kimberly
wants from me so if you know what she
wants and you're not willing to give it
to her
why are you there
why are you playing games with this
woman so it's not just a bed that looks
good right
i mean
oh
kim shows off her nightgown and say what
you want about her but she has some
confidence hey you looking good
it can come off as thirsty for sure but
truth be told her actions take a lot of
courage so why don't you go ahead and
get comfortable and i'll bring you a
glasses champagne okay all right usman
gets comfy and takes off his shirt while
kim gets the bubbly going but then it
starts to get a little weird let me pull
you
are you like that
oh i am uncomfortable i don't know what
was going on there but as they get into
bed kim brings up sex of course she did
and after usman says no it's not going
to happen things take a turn for the
worse i wasn't injured why are you
rushing
i i want to why don't you want to have
sex with me though i don't understand we
will have sex
[Music]
when listening like what else do i have
you know i'm really like legit about to
cry let me don't cry like why why why is
this not enough damn
like i said from the beginning kim has
been setting herself up for this
disappointment but at the same time
my heart goes out to her because
rejection is never a good feeling
especially when you feel as if you're
giving your best and it's still not
enough
that sucks
you just don't want me to just admit you
don't want me if you if you admit that
i'm i'm fine
no like i didn't you you just don't want
no i didn't say that
if i don't want you i will not invite
you
right
i'm gonna get some more champagne
because i can't live like that with that
more champagne is not what she needs
right now because her emotions are up
down up down in large part due to usmen
leading her on yes kim is being overly
assertive but at the same time i think
usman should take some responsibility
for her behavior as well he's just
dangling a relationship in her face
knowing she is extremely into him and
he's not that into her that's not cool
because kim won't let go of the sex
conversation usman decides to leave her
room you've been pushing pushing for me
to move into a room i move immediately i
get into room you want me to have sex
with you that is no right kim goes after
him apologizes and he comes back after
she promises to stop pressuring him you
can't do that like that without like
talking to me
i move into a room
and you come with different concepts
example have facts is that bad it's not
bad but like allow it to happen
naturally when we are making a decision
to be a boyfriend and girlfriend but
like i don't know how you feel and that
bothers me it bothers me so bad like
tell me how you feel about me like tell
me i am so much like you i'm telling you
that's so bad to say kim went on to
share that she's afraid she's going to
go home heartbroken and have to tell her
friends her son and her mom that they
were all right about usmen see this is
why you don't hype stuff up to people
because you don't have to be embarrassed
when it doesn't work out
good night
[Music]
i can't
excuse me
[Music]
i can't do it
tensions rise once again when oozman
tells kim goodnight and she's not done
talking about the situation
what are you wanting to happen right now
like i can't i can't i can't do this
because my friend's gonna cut him out
and i don't want that to happen he's
gonna do it he's gonna cut you out like
a dog
he cannot do that no he can't i have no
business with him
he's my son now
in my opinion kim is making this
something that it's not by bringing her
son into this i'm sure he would love to
curse usman out but the reality is
kim has done a lot of this to herself
so if her son needs to have a
conversation with anybody
it's her do you think my son would love
that when you're treating me right now
oh my do you think you might have that
yes you are why you're making it look
bad bringing her son into this
conversation is totally wrong what do i
have to do with your son
[Music]
this is best you have to get into
profile approval y'all haven't even
kissed yet yeah yeah from him yes no
he's my kid
that's what he is and that's what he
will ever be jamal has questions about
your intentions with me
jamal should make that note it's always
been me and jamal
i don't want to talk to you
and if that's the only one who can be
together no problem i don't want to be
together with you to my surprise after
all of that usman got back in the bed
you're dressed
a future without usment is scary to me
because he's like all i've known for the
past year a year
kim you've spent 49 of them without him
girl you got this
anyway they both eventually prepare to
go to sleep but kim admits the way usman
disrespected her son rubs her the wrong
way
it makes me question everything all
right well speaking of questioning
everything
some things to keep on your radar for
next week is jasmine reacting to gino
sending naked pictures of her to his ex
you are the president you're sick sir
gino
why
i can't wait to hear his explanation
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with et because we are covering it
all i will see you next time
[Music]
you